bene parlare di cura adesso dopo queste
immagini della guerra e del dolore che
viene con la guerra forse viene come
dire al momento giusto m Che cos'è la
cura la cura la riceviamo tutti si parla
normalmente si usa normalmente questa
parola cura però nella filosofia
occidentale non è mai stata oggetto
recentemente di considerazione se non a
partire dagli anni 80 negli Stati Uniti
a seguito di un libro di una psicologa
Carol gilligan la quale ha messo in
discussione l'idea che l'etica deva
essere costruita solo sull'idea di
giustizia e attraverso una sua ricerca
fatta sul pensiero degli adolescenti Ha
ipotizzato che ci siano due modi di
pensare all'etica quella che lei chiama
la voice of Just e la voice of care a
partire da quel suo studio che è datato
1981 nasce tutto il pensiero
contemporaneo sulla cura e quando si
studia questo argomento sembra davvero
che tutto sia nato in quegli anni in
realtà ci si dimentica che il tema della
cura è alla base della nostra filosofia
occidentale alla base del pensiero
occidentale c'è un testo poco studiato
quando si studia Platone ma molto bello
che è il politico il dialogo il politico
dove Platone dà una definizione della
politica e dice che la politica è l'ep
melei coinè è l'aver cura della comunità
Ecco questo Bisognerebbe studiare oggi
ripensare la politica come cura della
Comunità ma sempre Platone insegna che
tutto il processo di formazione il
processo di educazione è un atto di cura
quando nell'al CBI che è un dialogo
importante l'al cbia de primo questo
giovanetto di Atene che vorrebbe
diventare un governante di questa
importante città e si rivolge a Socrate
per chiedere cosa dovrebbe apprendere
Socrate gli dice Devi aver cura di te e
al cibia gli chiede Ma cosa significa
aver cura di sé e Socrate risponde con
questa espressione aver cura di sé
significa epimeleia psyches che aver
cura dell'anima Ecco tutta tutti il
pensiero della filosofia prima il
pensiero da cui nasce la nostra cultura
è sulla cura poi è stata dimenticata
Oggi la riprendiamo rimettiamo al centro
dell'attenzione Ma che cosa significa
che cos'è la cura In poche parole
possiamo dire che la cura è prendersi a
cuore la vita Questo è il significato
più vero più
profondo una grande filosofa del 900 che
Simon veale dice che tutti gli esseri
umani cercano due cose cercano un po' di
bene e di evitare il male il dolore Ecco
il lavoro della cura è questo il lavoro
della cura è cercare di procurare quel
bene di cui l'anima sente necessità ed
evitare per quanto possibile il dolore
che in qualche modo la vita
sempre porta ecco della cura si può
parlare in modo argomentativo come
stiamo facendo o narrativo raccontando
storie
ehm Per questo ho pensato che il modo
migliore di entrare nell'argomento sia
quello di raccontare una storia una
delle tante che ho raccolto nella la mia
ricerca Questa è la storia che mi è
stata raccontata da una medica che
lavora nei servizi domiciliari di
oncologia siamo appunto nelle cure
palliative e mi
scrive Roberto è un uomo giovane 48 anni
sposato e papà di due bimbi è malato da
molto tempo ormai le energie lo stanno
abbandonando quando va a casa Vado a
casa per la visita è sempre silenzioso
non parla gli occhi sono umidi Anzi
bagnati di sofferenza
lo sguardo è intenso però appesantito è
quello di chi da troppo tempo non sa
come fare per tenere a bada il dolore
mentre lo visito in silenzio mi guarda
non si lamenta mai non dice nulla a
parlare sono io per rompere il silenzio
racconto quello che mi accade durante la
giornata quello che mi accade al lavoro
quello che fanno i miei bimbi Roberto
Ascolta un pomeriggio Finita la visita
al momento del saluto mi chiede
quando torni Io fra due giorni come al
solito Roberto ma non ce la fai a
passare prima
eh sento spesso paura e sento che
appesantisci con questa paura anche mia
moglie la sento la sua fatica ho bisogno
del tuo aiuto io ma non so non so Vedo
Roberto cosa posso fare Mi sento un po'
impacciata in quel momento vado in out
parto lungo la strada ci penso penso che
ho tante cose da fare la sera arrivo a
casa sempre molto stanca poi però m
faccio un calcolo Questa è l'espressione
che lei usa faccio un calcolo e comincio
a pensare cosa è opportuno fare se è
opportuno togliere da qualche parte e
così mi organizzo ogni giorno a fine
giornata passo anche solo per un saluto
ma passo Clara mi aspetta Clara è la
moglie lo sa e mi lascia per all porta
di casa così che possa entrare con
facilità resto poco ma abbastanza per
vedere un po' di leggerezza nel suo
sguardo per chiedergli come sta per
sedermi un attimo accanto a lui e per
aggiustare le cose della terapia un
pomeriggio Finita la visita Roberto mi
dice Chiara rimani a cena da noi Clara
ha preparato la pizza e forse l'ultima
che posso condividere con la mia
famiglia
sarei contento se resti qui la tua
presenza è importante veramente rispondo
subito perché siamo abituati le scrivere
a rispondere sempre di getto con tanta
fretta Avrei un
impegno Roberto abbassa lo sguardo non
dice nulla allora anche qui faccio un
calcolo veloce e trovo una soluzione e
chiamo Federico Federico è il marito
Fede puoi andare tu per favore a
prendere i bimbi a basket brontola un
po' poi dice vabbè ci vado io
Ecco l'organizzazione è fatta
e esco perché comunque devo fare delle
cose prima in in ospedale poi torno i
bimbi di Roberto sono contenti c'è
un'altra persona a casa Roberto non
riesce a mangiare però è lì e Per un
attimo mi sembra di non vedere più
quella pesantezza nel suo
sguardo è una bella serata intanto mi
riposo anch'io sua moglie è molto
gentile sembra serena anche lei il
giorno dopo come solito passo Clara
viene ad accogliermi non c'è la porta
aperta c'è lei che mi aspetta ha gli
occhi lucidi di chi ha pianto molto e
dice Chiara Roberto ci ha lasciati ha
scritto questo biglietto per te Vieni in
cucina ti ho preparato una tazza di tè
Io entro mi siedo prendo quel foglietto
la scrittura incerta ma il senso è
chiaro grazie per la cura che hai avuto
per noi
no Ecco questo è il racconto che questa
medica mi ha voluto condividere di uno
dei tanti lavori che fanno i medici che
sanno aver cura dei loro pazienti
l'abbiamo scoperto durante il periodo
del covid ce l'hanno detto infermieri ce
li hanno detti i medici quelli con i
quali abbiamo fatto ricerche che la cura
non è solo fornire delle terapie per la
cura Fisica c'è anche la cura dell'anima
Platone lo scriveva nel Gorgia un bravo
medico è colui che si prende cura
dell'altro non solo con le erbe per noi
farmaci ma con i logoi cioè con le
parole Chiara lo fa lo fa quando parla
delle altre cose mentre Roberto è in
silenzio
e lo fa quando Cerca qualche parola per
la moglie ma lo fa soprattutto trovando
del tempo che non è il tempo previsto
dal suo lavoro lo fa perché capisce che
l'altro ha un grande bisogno del suo
aiuto in quel momento e Adotta una
logica quando lei dice calcolo eh Faccio
dei calcoli che non è la logica
contabile è un altro calcolo il calcolo
etico ci sono delle cose
importanti però la nostra vita spesso è
piena di cose non importanti non sempre
riusciamo a trovare la giusta misura non
sempre riusciamo ad agire secondo quello
che scheller chiamava lordo amoris cioè
l'ordine delle cose di valore e in quei
momenti lì quando ti trovi di fronte al
dolore più duro Allora se guardi lo
sguardo dell'altro se ti lasci
interpellare dallo sguardo dell'altro
come dice un grande filosofo che emuele
vinas se ti lasci toccare fino in fondo
Allora tutto ti scombina e trovi la
misura per fare i calcoli Giusti e
questo è il lavoro della cura andare
incontro all'altro cercando di
restituire all quello di cui ha bisogno
per vivere questa è la cura ospedaliera
la cura sanitaria i sanitari durante il
covid subito dopo ci dicevano abbiamo
riscoperto Cosa significa la cura al
letto del paziente e la sofferenza che
hanno patito che si sono portati dietro
era il vedere molti pazienti soffrire
senza i parenti attorno e stavano male
anche loro Quindi c'è stata una
riscoperta del senso profondo della cura
sanitaria che è cura del corpo e cura
dell'anima però la cura non è solo
quella abbiamo detto c'è la la politica
che è cura della comunità c'è la cura
sanitaria che ha cura del malato di chi
ha il suo corpo o la sua anima inceppata
da un dolore da una sofferenza ma c'è
anche la cura
educativa si dimentica di risignificare
il lavoro dell'educazione come un lavoro
di cura che è cura della vita della
mente l'educazione non è solo istruzione
non è solo fornire delle Scienze dei
saperi Sì certo servono servono per
entrare nel mondo del lavoro ma i nostri
bambini le nostre bambine i ragazzi e le
ragazze entreranno Innanzitutto nel
mondo della vita e allora quel
significato profondo Eh che ci che ci ha
consegnato Platone attraverso i suoi
dialoghi che ci dice di aver cura
dell'anima dovrebbe essere rimesso al
centro dell'azione
educativa molti sono i racconti Eh che
si raccolgono dagli insegnanti Bravi
bravi nel senso capaci di cura
quello che ho scelto di raccontare qua
oggi questo lo racconto a mente perché
quasi lo so lo so a memoria perché per
me un paradigma per risignificare tutto
il lavoro di interpretazione dei testi è
quello che mi è stato raccontato da un
insegnante aveva terminato la prima
elementare
Eh e In questa prima c'era i bambini
sapete non amano tanto la matematica in
genere No ce n'erano alcuni un po' in
difficoltà uno in particolare lei va al
mare con i suoi bambini con i suoi figli
e lungo la spiaggia raccoglie le
conchiglie poi raccoglie dei sassi e
Raccoglie anche nella pineta delle pigne
e le mette nei sacchetti questo Questi
materiali servono sono importanti per
sviluppare le capacità logiche a partire
dal lavoro con le mani e però prepara un
sacchetto un sacchetto a parte per
Cristian perché Cristian è molto in
difficoltà Quindi lei vorrà fare un
lavoro con lui individualmente
arriva in classe il primo primo giorno
della seconda prepara tutti i sacchetti
li mette sul tavolo prepara tutto il
lavoro per l'anno poi Chiama Cristian
dice Cristian Questo però mettilo sotto
il tuo banco perché è per te come per me
maestra Sì sì per te guarda li ho
raccolti quando ero sulla spiaggia e
questi li ho pensati per te lui si ferma
e le chiede per me sì Cristian te l'ho
detto sono per te ma allora durante le
vacanze hai pensato a me Certo che ho
pensato a te lui rimane strabiglia poi
Appoggia il sacchetto e comincia a
saltare per la classe la maestra
Elisabetta ha pensato a me per le
vacanze e e riempie No la la sua classe
di questo pensiero di queste parole
Elisabetta rimane Colpita e poi mi dice
quando ci troviamo nel contesto della
ricerca io non avevo pensato di fare una
cosa così importante Eppure per
Christian è stato importante che io gli
abbia detto che pensavo a lui certo
perché l'atto di
cura è l'atto magari con una piccola
cosa con cui mettiamo l'altro al centro
delle nostre attenzioni Christian in
quel momento si era sentito dentro la
mente della sua maestra dentro il suo
sguardo e dentro il suo pensiero dentro
il suo sentire e quindi si è sentito
importante si è sentito avere valore e
tutti cerchiamo un po' di riconoscimento
tutti cerchiamo un po' di valore e la
cura è la capacità innanzitutto di dare
valore all'altro all'altro che abbiamo
di fronte
ehm Molte sono le cose che si possono
dire su questa che è l'attività
fondamentale della vita è il lavoro del
vivere il lavoro di cura o meglio l'arte
dell'esistenza Eh quando diventa cura di
sé quando diventa cura per l'altro cura
per le istituzioni perché le istituzioni
la scuola gli ospedali questo teatro non
sono solo commodity non sono solo cose
utili che noi utilizziamo ma sono beni
di cui avere cura e poi la cura della
natura perché che questa è una cosa che
abbiamo dimenticato di coltivare dentro
il processo educativo la natura è il
luogo dal quale Noi viviamo è la fonte
originaria della vita ed è solo avendo
cura della natura che abbiamo cura anche
di noi ecco per fare questo lavoro della
cura di sé degli altri del mondo e della
natura ci vuole un grande lavoro un
cambio di paradigma nella nostra cultura
che chiede di imparare un un nuovo modo
di essere nel mondo quello che ci ha
significato Chiara mentre cur Roberto
che ha messo in atto quelle cose un po'
che hanno un nome Un po' antico che sono
le virtù Eh la politica oggi la politica
della cura ha bisogno di nuove virtù la
cultura la virtù del
rispetto la virtù della generosità di
dare il tempo all'altro che il dono più
grande Seneca diceva la cosa peggiore è
l'incuria non aver cura della vita e
l'incuria del tempo cioè dello sprecare
il tempo Chiara non l'ha sprecato ha
fatto di quel tempo di cui aveva a
disposizione un dono per Roberto Ecco la
generosità è come dire la legge
economica della cura che è il diverso
l'assolutamente contrario della
contabilità Cosa può fare cosa fa
qualcuno che è capace di cura chi è
capace di cura è come se facesse quello
che il mondo attorno a una pianta fa
rispetto alla pianta la pianta riesce a
sintetizzare l'energia perché è capace
di clorofila essere capace di cura vuol
dire riuscire ad aiutare l'altro e anche
se stessi a trovare quella clorofilla
spirituale che ci aiuta a stare bene nel
tempo e a realizzare quell'umanità che
ci è dato come onere di realizzare nella
vita
[Applauso]
grazie